dallas kykel to the mound on for his
21st start looking for his eighth win is
the era of four and a half
you see left-handers mysteriously
hitting 290 against and that's somewhat
surprising because he always fared well
against the lefties but he's thrown too
many home run balls 20 of them this year
whitmer field as he leads things off for
kansas city
and the ground ball back to the
four-time gold glover
no slight to anybody else on the field
but when dallas kykel pitches he is the
best defender
for the white sox the royals have two on
with two out and the rookie emmanuel
rivera will step up paula sets up inside
that was out over the plane and it's
lying to center
and engel got turned around twice
the royals have one run home they have
two runs home
rivera
i think hit it so squarely that he sent
a knuckle ball out to center field and
engel got twisted into the ground way to
go emmanuel see he didn't miss he waited
he got it and he barreled it he turned
engel into a pretzel and daniel lynch
royal's number two prospect entering
2021 his first big league win was a
couple of starts ago against the tigers
with eight scoreless innings jose abreu
will hit with two out and no one on he
homered last night lynch goes into the
line the o2 pitch fly ball left center
tailored back track wall home runs in
back-to-back games for jose abreu
sox cut the lead in half
on an afraid you homer his 20th of the
year 2-1 he's starting to heat up again
[Music]
that's a swing
so lynch
recovers after a brayuse home run
and it's 2-1 royals at the end of one
first pitch to gallagher gets by savala
in and out of the mid so taylor will run
down to second base
on what i think may be a pass ball yeah
no i think you're correct
call strike three dallas needed that
that's his first strikeout tonight
now the batter is andrew vaughan
here's a slider swung on and missed
struck him out two strikeouts for daniel
tonight now lynch to face adam engel
and engel on a 3-2 pitch hits it off the
end of the bat here comes taylor and
he's got it
so lynch gets the white sox one two
three in the bottom of the second and
the royals lead 2-1
and now one down to salvador perez who
is singled and scored
golf to left
where garcia's roaming
himself he thought he should hit that
one out he's most unhappy with himself
he got a hittable pitch and got under it
kykel starting to settle in that's a one
two three third still 2-1 for the
visitors
and he's since then really settled in
that's not where gallagher wanted and
you could see daniel lynch was shaking
his head even though he got the
strikeout gallagher wanted this in the
dirt
but daniel gets a strikeout nonetheless
so first time through and daniel lynch
has set down eight of nine
oh beautiful finish
he has retired seven in a row and nine
of ten
wide open stance
through the hole in the left
good way to start it off
jimenez
a called third strike on a fastball and
lynch has struck out five with a
better strike zone tonight than the one
he had friday in toronto yes pitcher and
catcher talk it over before moncotta
bats two on two out fourth inning
knock down that slatter hit him
got him low
and he is slow to get up james crock out
to check on him the bases will be loaded
looks like he will
head down to first
so nowhere to put right handed hitting
adam engel their center fielder delivers
and a swing and a miss he struck him out
with a fastball at the knees at 96 and
daniel lynch pounds his glove happy to
get out of that jam with a bases loaded
a strikeout his sixth of the night
here's leori garcia to lead off the sox
fifth against
daniel lynch
1-0 swung on right side and right past
carlos santana a lead-off single from
leori garcia shot one the other way but
now moving into scoring position is
leori garcia now saves our hernandez
and it's hit to right
dozier is there and the inning is over
so he played five in chicago and the
royals lead 2-1
michael looking for another ground ball
but this time at somebody
and he got him on an inside cutter that
pitch was
five or six inches off the plate four
strikeouts against three walks
he struck him out
well the two punch-outs coming on the
cutter here in the sixth
rivera with that two-run double in the
first
3-1 lined out into right that's andrew
vaughn who makes a diving stab and the
play
andrew vaughn can play a little right
and the white sox have two on with
nobody out
and that's going to be it for daniel
lynch so it's probably pitch count more
than anything else and he has labored a
lot more
in the last three compared to the first
three but all in all
it's another encouraging start for him
absolutely
grounded seven double plays like to make
it eight here
that curve stayed up and rivera cuts it
off
and good call hud
two down runner at third and the batter
will be their third baseman moncada
breaking ball is out over the plate and
carlos santana will go to the bag and
get monkata way to pick up daniel lynch
he's pumped
elivares grounded to third twice against
kykel
olivares into deep right center field
and engel is at the wall did he get it
he did not edward olivares
goes to the opposite field and we were
all waiting to see if engel got it
he did not and it's another home run
holy boris
fourth of the year his third since being
called back up
and the royals lead 3-1 in the seventh
oh man how about that
hernandez still the runner at first sox
have a chance to tie it with a long one
eloy strike struck out twice
lined
fair into the corner
took a squirrelly hop
hernandez around third he will score so
they get the run
and it's three to two
[Applause]
and they lead in this one three to two
with two out in the ninth and it'll be
larry garcia
ground ball out to nikki lopez
and that is in time and the royals take
two out of three from the white sox
the final score three to two